[Music]
welcome back to CBS This Morning a
suspect who was already in police
custody now faces charges in the Ambush
shooting of two Los Angeles County
sheriff's deputies and a reminder the
video of that shooting may be upsetting
to some viewers the deputies were
targeted as they sat in their Cruiser
last month and they were both seriously
wounded in the incident 36-year-old
Deontay Lee Murray pleaded not guilty to
two counts of attempted murder of a
peace officer Carter Evans reports now
from Los Angeles this grainy video
captured the moment a gunman opened fire
directly into the SUV of two Los Angeles
sheriff's deputies setting off a man
hunt that lasted almost 3 weeks on
September 12th of this year in Compton
we saw the worst of humanity now
detectives in Los Angeles believe they
finally have their man charging Deontay
Lee Murray with attempted murder of a
peace officer for the unprovoked Ambush
we've all seen the shocking surveillance
video that video plus other compelling
forensic evidence are the basis for this
prosecution he was arrested two weeks
ago in connection with a carjacking he
led police on a chase and engaged in a
standoff lasting more than 10 hours
during that Pursuit the suspect threw a
pistol from his car that pistol was
conclusively linked through forensic
testing to suspect Deontay Murray at the
time investigators were adamant that two
cases were not connected it seems
deliberately misleading when you
strongly suspected going into it that
this may have been the guy but you
definitively said he wasn't we're not
going to tell you all of our suspicions
because you don't give away the story
police say a ballistic comparison
confirmed that Murray's pistol was the
same weapon used in the attack on the
deputies now both of them a 31-year-old
mother and her 24-year-old male partner
are recovering at home they still face a
lot of surgery reconstructive surgery
and that's going to be a lengthy process
but
fortunately they're doing
okay now Deontay Lee Murray is currently
in jail behind me his bail set at more
than $6 million now prosecutors have
requested that no photos of Murray be
released saying it could jeopardize the
investigation if he is convicted of the
charges against him he faces life in
prison Gail Carter authorities not
messing around with a bail that high $6
million I'm glad they have a suspect in
custody but really happy that the two
deputies are home home with their
families I know you said they have a
long recovery ahead of time ahead do do
does anyone know if they'll eventually
be able to go back to their jobs or is
it much too early to even think about
that at this
point we asked the sheriff that
yesterday and he says yes when they
recover he expects him back on the job
oh that's very good news thank you very
much Carter Evans